[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake I'm
very excited to be talking about spatial
computing we have the founders of
infinite retina joining us
Irina Cronin Robert Scovill hello you
two hello thanks for coming back onto
the show for round yellow for both of
you
yeah super pom super pumped you guys are
both of the early stages of the show now
we've made it up to almost episode 400
now and here you are having started
infinite retina that means you're gonna
ask tougher questions our jobs you've
gotten more wisdom on your side as well
you've found it infinite retina which is
a spatial computing agency helping
entrepreneurs and fortune 500 companies
understand spatial computing in order to
create new companies and divisions
infinite reddit.com the link is below
also on twitter at infinite retina and
both Irena and Roberts LinkedIn profiles
are linked below as well so you're
holding the hololens there we have so
much to talk about regarding the magic
leap and all of the future applications
of this type of these technologies
that's right that's right and let's
start things off with our epic question
about the state of humanity we find
ourselves as stewards of earth yes what
is your current take on the state female
I'm Irina and I have been talking about
a lot about this and we see a perfect
storm of change coming
over the next decade the 2020s are gonna
see more change for humans particularly
in technology than we have ever seen
right more data is gonna get created in
the next few years then has ever been
created I mean we just were talking
about the Tesla when it goes down the
street and it sucks the data for a
mystery right with twenty billion
transistors yes on a little chip yeah
runs just right you start thinking about
okay yeah on Saturday night I was
walking through a Cray supercomputer
right which has hundreds of miles of
wire and very few transistors compared
to the little chip that's running a
Tesla car today
right and that cost millions of dollars
at the beginning of my career right yeah
it's crazy what's happened in our lives
and we're about to see more change so
let's talk about Shana's right
autonomous cars are a variety autonomous
vehicles are riding you're starting to
see it we are Tesla drove us here from
Campbell right most of the way really
well really well yeah and you guys were
just chillin chillin
I never had an issue there's something
about by the way I can tell when I take
somebody out and they turn on autopilot
I can tell that the computers driving
because it's really smooth on the Linux
and when that when it goes back to a
human driving out there inconsistently
they drift around the lane a little bit
and I can tell that right but I mean in
terms of the different types of
Technology so it's it's spatial
computing which is competing you can
move through it includes a R VR an AI
robot a machine learning computer vision
everything that you would need the
technology and software to be able to
move in a three-dimensional world
okay so that is a lot yeah right so it's
not only one thing it's that people are
talking about AR AR s different than BR
and then there's AI and then there's
autonomous cars it's there's a lot that
it connects all of these different
technologies and it should be viewed
like that because it is all about three
dimensionality and at the same time our
cloud computing is ratcheting up to
something new yeah we haven't yet you
know think we were arguing on the way
here what why don't we call this thing
that's in the sky that we're talking you
know i i'd joke around that's like a god
but yeah but it's alexa or siri right or
google assistant where it's listening to
me full-time in my house i have these
all over the house right and on my
computer and on my phone right i can say
hey Siri and it'll come up and start
doing things right us yes we're about to
see new cryptocurrency right and and
everything that comes along with that
decentralized computing and a new
architecture and we probably in this
decade we're gonna see quantum computing
really feminine so that we're about to
hit people with a lot of chain and we
have iam guiding all the weeds right I
mean I start talking to somebody about
this for you guys oh you totally forgot
about what's going on in genetics
research right and it's like there's
another revolution happening there right
that's true and there's others right all
hitting at the same time so humans are
gonna see a lot of change let's just
talk about America America what's the
number one job truck driving that job is
going away yeah I can state that
definitively that if you're a truck
driver you will probably not have your
job in 15 years probably less
why because the self-driving truck is
cheaper than you are and safer and safer
and by the way the truckers themselves
are gonna buy it first cuz they're paid
by the load right if I need a load
carried from Oakland port to New York
for some reason I call up a trekking
broker and I pay by the load and so the
trekker is gonna be very incentive to
buy one of these new Tesla and there's
others Daimler doesn't look Volvo it
they're all building these autonomous
tracks why because have you ever driven
across the United States mm-hmm I have I
did it last summer it's really hard and
if you're a trekker you have to stop
every so often I think it's every 12 and
10 or 12 hours No get some sleep well
yeah and stop right and there's a log
that you have to fill out you have to
stop
well what's right around 10 hours Nevada
what's Nevada it's a straight road with
no pedestrians no cross traffic right
it's a boring road to drive right can
you push a button go in the back and
sleep for four hours while it drives
across them on it hell yeah you can and
now you don't have to stop so your load
will get to the other side of the
country faster you'll get paid more so
so you'll buy a new truck because you're
getting paid more on every load I just
want something that a lot of people are
saying yeah there's going to be many
many people who will lose their jobs but
it's not going to be that their whole
job is gonna be gone it'll take at least
20 years or maybe more depending on the
type of job where the person is actually
working doing a job and then doing
something that's automated or helping
the automated people even work it's just
gonna and sometimes it's gonna stay like
that it's about even in this step let's
stay on truck trip yes right because now
let's say a truck driver buys a Tesla
truck to drive cross-country and he or
she is
stopping any more person lost their job
at the hotel that used to manage their
and the the the cafe where they used to
stop to get food right right and all the
other jobs America is about to
reconfigure so we haven't figure out
what kind of jobs are gonna have in the
future okay let's do a cultural changes
that are going to be okay I'll hit the
tennis ball back let's see how well I
can do here all right so the 2020 is
there gonna be a massively profound
shift for us across all the sectors one
of the main things that we see right now
is we see all of the technology
decreasing in cost increasing in
efficiency decreasing in size and we
yeah look at that that's a that's a 360
camera right there yeah they put it on a
little stick
this camera four years ago my first
camera I took the first 360 video at
Coachella four years ago and my camera
cost three thousand dollars this camera
cost four hundred dollars and is way way
way better than the camera is four years
ago right not even in the clip I mean
the computer vision that's going on in
this thing
and I we should pull out my phone so you
can see how steady it is but it's
looking around the room and doing
machine learning to see the room and
steady it out it's freaking amazing
right cuz I could shake it like this and
it's still that is it it's nuts
right and with just two wide angled
cameras it can sense this is seeing in
360 big seeing in 360 degrees including
up and down and left and right and it's
then it's doing a little stitch line and
yeah it's very darted some prototypes
and R&D lives where this is built into
your cell phone yeah that's that's right
so you're holding your phone
years up in the air you know if you're
in the front row of Beyonce right you're
gonna hold your phone up like this and
you're gonna be broadcasting in 360 to
people who are wearing some sort of
thing on their face and able to
experience what it's like to be in the
front row moving through it yeah yeah
yeah yeah or at least yeah you know and
by the way this camera does two things
Rennie it does also 3d 180 II that's
very interesting the - yeah correct what
haiti's actually really duplicates your
eyes yeah yeah correct and and that's
that's also gonna be a big deal coming
sim right in the next two years yes yes
those two things of being experiencial
being able to see what what a place
feels like all the way around like this
this I can take you into this room yeah
that's correct or be able to see it in
3d and see you and this is mostly a
consumer thing so yeah bucks just to let
you know if your retina is working with
enterprise yeah okay we're not dealing
with consumer level right now because
spatial computing is not ready for that
Holly in another two to three years it
will be but there's a lot going on right
now which is stopping it from turning
into a consumer product of this is being
used by Walmart to train their employees
and new way and they bought 17,000 for a
headset so there are implications even
yes ok yeah ok I'll continue with a
little little hit back it's also very
interesting that you take this all the
way into not only Moore's law but then
also the Carlson curve in biotech as
well and all the implications there in
neuro tech and then to decentralization
and the Internet of Things and the
amount of data that we create in every
two years is is equal to 90% of all the
data that's ever been on yeah it's just
continuing to have it's exponentially
going up right date of the self-driving
car this self-driving car as it drives
down the street just
sup all this data right and soon we're
gonna have that on our glasses we're
gonna have little cameras I met that
guys who built the lg camera which has
the camera here well you also have a
Google you know the building's they're
able to see through buildings and their
mapping out just whole streets that's
you're seeing Apple and Google
yeah others carrying backpacks with
cameras sort of like this yeah
Enterprise cameras that are slurping up
all the data to get a 3d model of the
world right yeah and there's a company
here in San Francisco called sixty-day I
which builds a map of your house with a
cell phone with their cell phone yeah
cellphone right okay so the so the we
actually when we had Andra k on the show
she also explained it like a Cambrian
explosion except for a robotic
perception and that's yeah and so it's
that's a really profound way of looking
at things because the if you were also
going into buildings with it as well
it's not just mapping streets it's
mapping inside of buildings inside of
houses the interconnectedness of all of
these it's also profound too you know
you had your two children in the back of
the Tesla in your video and it's just
like your kids are growing up with an
autonomous car your kids are growing up
being educated with augmented reality
yeah yeah and I wonder how the neural
circuitry wires and remembers data based
on a 3d model of that gastrointestinal
tract in the biology beyond system into
solar systems then from a text yeah
she says better oh then a textbook and I
was SEOs know I was thinking like if if
if you teach me something like how to
cook a meal right and then I see it in
VR do I learn the same I say it's just
it's the same compared to a textbook
yeah I knew it's doing it's not even
close you're teaching people how to fix
a million dollar tractor at caterpillar
with augmented reality in real time on
the tractor without doing a book without
doing a pasture
in real time yeah I mean we're working
with certain heads who are doing this
kind of training on real - in real time
on top for the surgery patient they're
wrapping the MRI skin on top of the
bottle we have at the bar you have a new
client that is about to get a new trial
and we'll be working with the FDA's
shortly to do surgery for cancer
patients using the hololens yeah on the
spot it's more accurate than the system
that existed before so the the amount of
innovation that is happening in so many
different areas is astounding and the
cut that just the people that are
thousands of people working in the same
kind of areas I said spatial computing
but the different verticals for
different kinds of reasons and effects
and yeah it's it's just it's it's just
it's very difficult for people to see
because it's done at a private level a
lot of these companies are very very
either really small entrepreneurial
companies or they're larger companies
that are private and don't want to talk
about it or they're Hollywood studios
that will never tell you what's going on
and the information flow is extremely
bad as a result and reporters can't get
the information so people really don't
know what's goin till it gets announced
and it's hard to get a demo of what the
magic is here because you can capture
this all day long I can't really show
what this is like to wear and ya see see
aliens coming out of your walls right or
see information laid over a factory
floor right in here it's not follow a
guided meditation it's fast there's
there's a there's another thing here
it's not only like you were describing
earlier not only being used for the
education of children and how that's a
profound shift but also to do real-time
surgery
real-time machinery work one of the
things with yes we can write an equation
yeah in the air and it shows you the
molecules joining in the air I wish I
had this as a tool when I was in school
yeah right and just on on on the quick
point there is that when considering the
amount of conversation that's occurring
around the planet around the the job
loss with automation
it's the simultaneously extremely
important to realize that the
organizations that are able to figure
out how to most effectively train people
for the decentralized IO T's automation
infrastructures programming and all
these different environments these are
the jobs that are opening up by the
hundreds of millions that just we need
the proper tools to do the retraining z'
and the young people are coming in to
the exactly we just visited intel down
in hollywood right down in LA
it's a Manhattan Beach it's the Intel
studios it's a volumetric studio so it's
separated from a tablet go ahead yeah
but what's happening if you go to
Universal Studios and do the little tour
right they take you around all these
warehouses and these sets physical set
yeah that's how they used to do movies
right they're getting rare though
they're digitizing every physical thing
so like this cup now if it's in a movie
is not a cup at all it's a scanned 3d
item that a director you know did this
decides needs to be on the table and
appends click-and-drag for implementing
and the studio is a huge dome it's all
green on the sides so they can replace
the walls with whatever they want right
there they had a hundred and sixty eight
cameras around it with a data center of
Intel computers in the
yeah so that they could make crazy I
mean they're using the techniques that
are using in this little tiny 400 dollar
camera tied in a multi-million dollar
studio to make movies and TV shows all
virtually and you think about the jobs
that are there they're all very new and
very different the person who used to
take care of the physical sets their
jobs gone or going away like now right
that person needs to be retrained and
there's actually a school that tests
this virtual film school I touched a
founder and he found a way to treat
trained people faster and cheaper than
going back to film school and doing it
old-style so yeah because you only need
to learn a very small curriculum of how
to do new things right how to do virtual
lights but your lights are physical in
the in the movies
they can move the lights to wherever
they need will be virtually and the
cameras are done in virtually right and
the sets are done virtually and the
effects you know we can blow this room
up and I'm moving right one person can
make an entire movie yeah somebody is
gonna come along then probably around 18
years old right now maybe 20 they're
gonna come along just like Robert
Rodriguez did and found a way to make
films cheaper with big-name actors and
he revolutionized the movie industry
back then same things gonna happen in
the next five years you're gonna see
somebody come along who figures out how
to tell stories a new way with this new
technology and does it very cheaply
because everything's virtualized
but hey or we go through this every day
there's always something that is just
like I can't believe this is true keep
in mind is happening there yeah how much
demand is there gonna be for this movie
I I had this conversation with the
company which I can't name over a year
ago which started even before Intel
Intel Studios knows about them and for
two days I was almost speechless I was
like yeah this is a new world 10x hunter
x you know cuz it soon you're gonna have
an IMAX on you
it's freaking out we create we create
our own universe we create our own
environment we make stories in that
environment
I mean imagine a sofa that is not at all
real but looks truly real yeah we place
it in the space wherever that is
we take an actress that is in another
location like in London we put her on
the sofa that is in this digital
location she sits down on that sofa and
it moves according to how her body has
moved on the sofa the mass of her body
on the soul it all it all adds up and
it's all in the white changes with her
it's all live right yeah they can do
that now and this was called a
volumetric dome yeah that's the theft of
place when I entered domes settings like
this they're completely digitally
created movies with with what could even
be the actors you can have a basketball
game in the in the dome so you could
have a basketball team in the dome
captured right in volumetric everything
is yeah is 3d grab that football
basketball team and do anything put in
the crowd is gonna be all virtualized
yeah so that calcium is gonna be
virtualized whatever you know everything
in movies is fake now this oh gee
Colosseum you know all the way to I was
flying like millions of people tuning in
live into I was flying back from Dubai
one time and I was sitting at the
counter at the lounge on it
Emirates right Emirates has a nice
lounge you can meet people what do you
do oh I just got done with Star Trek I
don't really what do you do what did you
do there yes I'm a costume designer and
I go tell me about that he goes well I
got in the business because my dad did
been hers costumes back in the 1560s
right when was Ben Hur done early and
they were very intricate costumes
because that's how they because he says
my job now is to put 32 white dots on an
actor whoa every to change everybody's
costume you saw in the latest Star Trek
yeah did not exist in the real world it
was virtually created by a costume
designer some are virtually and put on
on top of the actress so yeah nothing
you see in movies is real we feel just
that 80% of what's currently in movies
this year a cgi who's 80% mvi already
yes I I could not believe that but that
comes from a referee reputable so when
I've sent any of the CTO of Comcast I
said what is this new what does a new
pair of glasses that hooks into 5g and
lets us see a movie theater cut you know
cuz this was coming coming soon like two
three certainly no more than four years
four years from now we're gonna have a
thing on our face that's gonna be a lot
smaller than this that's gonna have four
eight sixteen thirty-two K screens
personalized for you
per I personalized it's gonna be like
you put an IMAX theater on your face
right and I'm gonna be I'm gonna be
playing with that in the three
dimensional space yes and you and it's
gonna be really powerful computing yes
that is potentially not even gonna be
locally occurring but occurring through
the fire exactly well so you yes so then
my the weight the harder here is now
gonna be write much hardware that's the
magic of 5g and that's why everybody is
going crazy about it yeah yeah 10 yes
we're gonna get there I know we're about
to get there if I explain to me just
quick one step back
are we talking physical environments
like these volumetric domes still being
relevant for people to physically come
and attend or are we talking to me being
able to be at home and observe it with
there to capture us because we still you
know an actor right of things okay pause
168th volumetric camera I stand in it or
a cup sits in it the couch sits at the
capture oh I see assemble it in this a
single filmmaker however many team can
assemble this in the CGI digital space
yes then this gets distributed to this
eight billion here yes
okay got it so these domes are important
for the capturing of physical items that
they're most granule what the highest
fidelity like yes got it
okay now 5g please yes yeah all right 5g
yeah ten what part of ten gigabits per
second to your glasses don't you
understand ten gigabits per second and
that's the start per second yeah ten
times faster than the LT the way I the
way wha way to put it it's like having a
fiber-optic cable to your phone yeah
fiber-optic directly to the phone yeah
there's a reason why Verizon is now
talking about 5g non-stop and it started
last year they made it part of their
messaging because it's it is super
powerful and that's why they're really
interested now in entertainment because
they can bring the weather 5g brings you
three things ten gigabits per second
maybe 25
Huawei was showing me twenty five twenty
five gigabits per second we're talking
about optimum obviously keep in mind
there's a lot of downsides let's just
talk about what they're gonna push at us
right they're gonna talk about the
bandwidth
they're gonna talk about latency to
millisecond latency millisecond that the
one of the CEOs I heard said it's zero
lates yes your brain can be tricked then
because you if the latency is under
whatever a hundred a milliseconds they
bring it strict right yeah and when I
went to the World Series game at AT&T
Park I pulled out my phone tried to take
a selfie I couldn't even make a phone
call in 18 t part that problem goes away
Elsa so there's three advantages of 5g
hey do you like ever download bandwidth
latency and the ubiquity more many more
devices per cell town / oppa many more
devices right IOT yes and robots robotic
cars right you can have a whole city
with thousand millions of devices yeah
and the infrastructure will stay up but
it seems as though a good amount of
infrastructure has to go up in order to
enable it we're talking like every
couple very couple blocks and used to go
up and so there was a conversation well
it was actually a Facebook kind of
dialogue with some engineers that I
recently had about some issues that
exist that Verizon and some other
companies they say are throttling them
because the costs are already starting
to add up
so because the costs are very expensive
there's going to be stuff that's going
to be not optimum until 5g goes up
there's issues with certain locations
it's not really clear at the at the last
what they say the last delivery point
how the 5g gets delivered so if that
system is antiquated what needs to get
done to fix it sometimes it's not
possible
tonight champion yeah 5g it's a higher
frequency it doesn't go through walls
very easily
so if you're inside and them and the
cell towers outside now you got to
figure out how to get that fast you know
a private entry yeah yeah interesting
yeah so that's also an issue and you
have to be within a kilometer and a half
of a cell tower right now LTE works ten
fifteen kilometers that's huge selfies
yeah yeah like you drive down LA you see
there's a cell tower way in the distance
right this is what I'm thinking about
these issues okay I'm sorry you have to
have a fiber line to that antenna yeah
yeah as it is with telecom and I've been
watching us for a while okay so at the
beginning when there's a new technology
everybody knows what the issues are
they're like it's not gonna get fixed or
get fixed in 25 years or something like
that and in evitable it takes about
eight to ten yeah right so engineers
start working on these issues and they
figured out new technologies that's
right that solve that and then there's
something new that comes up that's
better even so
night night frogs yeah I think right now
from when we're looking at it for the
next five years or so they're gonna be
these existing issues and she'll start
working on it if they're not doing some
entry point fixes right now on it and
it's gonna be fixed and then it's gonna
be 6g and whatever comes next right
which has its will have its own set of
issues okay question yeah okay all right
we have um some visual assets that yeah
can that Ron can pull up right now we
have some of the some of the newer
technologies the HTC vive focus the
magic leap yeah this is the vibe focus
and we have the magic lead I just want
to explain like the microsoft hololens
which you've pulled up with the - is the
next imaged in the oculus quest and then
in we skipped to the computer vision
image and then the Tesla autonomous car
yep yeah the computer vision
yeah yeah and I wanted to show these
because this directly ties into the
question that I'm about to ask because
the interconnectedness of the devices
that are both on top of our heads as
well as the devices like the autonomous
vehicles that are driving with the new
robotic perception that's occurring and
all the data that's streaming and from
that the a lot of the questions that
come up in conversations are around
security they're around ethics they're
around the there around the issues that
happen to our biology yeah and so I want
to I want to ask these questions now
okay one of the first questions is about
the headsets when we're looking at
devices that are already a foot away
from our faces we can literally feel our
eyesight deteriorating when we're not
looking at things far away from us
because that's how we evolved to look
further away than devices this close
okay that's one thing the focal points
already here so what's it gonna be the
change when the focal point one second
I'm almost done it's just a couple of
couple thoughts the focal point is gonna
be in the spatial environment so we can
explain in a moment yeah and the other
questions on the health are on the the
safety and the ethics around things like
harm potentially being done through the
autonomous vehicles being hacked into or
any there's things like that and then
the last question is about the 5g
infrastructure and the way that it
affects our biology yeah yeah and
because it's just so much everywhere so
please yes what are there somehow I mean
each one of those deserves an hour okay
that for instance on the front of the
hololens is four cameras right that
makes it 3d map of the room
that's what it's doing it's building a
3d point cloud of the room and then it
converts that to a polygon mesh and
overlaying on you as little triangles
right that's how it how it works
physically what happens if you walk in
wearing something like this into a
bathroom or if you're in a kitchen or
scanning something that maybe you don't
want the cloud to know that's problem we
have to as an industry have to figure
out how to do this to not freak people
out
certainly in bathrooms and you in four
years are going to be about this size
I'm going to replace my current pair of
glasses with a smart glass and I'm not
ever gonna take them off so they are
like no I do I'm gonna push it to the
utmost end and I am gonna wear them and
I'm not gonna I'm not saying I don't
know to that yeah what I'm saying is
people get used to things fairly quickly
alright if this becomes so ubiquitous as
you're talking about it's a cult then
becomes a cultural thing and you learn
when and when to use it and why not to
use it I know but the technology is
always firing no there's gonna be some
kind of failsafe built-in so it's not
always firing that's for the industry to
figure out how to do whenever maybe
whenever you reach a bathroom there's
like a little thing there and it shuts
it off automatically but we haven't seen
that yet right so these are issues that
have to be worked out when it comes to
cultural issues that's not the
difficulty that's not so difficult I
mean yes you had the issue with Google
glass that was a big cultural faux pas
right that's I don't think that's gonna
be replicated I think people are excited
to be able to use this this time around
are there lessons that were learned but
you're talking about health issues yeah
that's so
I will tell you that with VR when VR
first started coming out with the oculus
rift came out there were several
scientists that said that there are
issues of course especially with kids so
they were saying under 12 years old Sony
actually made a statement about that and
then took it back so I think it's kind
of an unknown issue but the more
sophisticated and better made the
headsets are the less these issues come
around so there's issues about the way
that you know everybody has a different
lens between right so that needs to be
you need to be able to fix that within a
headset whether it's an AR headset or a
VR headset you need to be able to get
your prescription lens yeah that already
solves a lot of issues with you know bad
eyesight there are cases of people
though that have bad eyesight they put
on the headset they see perfect yeah
because it's adjusting for it so anyway
yeah there's another side to this I met
with an eye doctor down in South Africa
sherilee called her she works with
professional Athens
she puts light into your eyes mm-hm and
exercises your eyes and makes your eyes
better yeah she took the worst rider on
the South African cycling team after
using her app for ten minutes a day for
six months he was the worst rider at
Falls per race on the team because he
had a perception problem that when he
got in the peloton which is the grouping
of bikes that's around you he would lose
focus and fall after six months of using
her app he's best on the team too
yeah damn ok so there's some ways to
augment health with technologies as well
of course it's just it's just there's a
lot of questions about 5g especially a
biology there's a lot of questions
around the security of ours just
propelling ourselves at 80 miles an hour
in an autonomous vehicle and then of
course why you're doing we already have
1500 billionaires on the planet that's
probably going to double within the next
couple of decades and a question becomes
the security teams are already massive
enough the what what ways are we
building out the next 20 20 s really in
terms of wealth they're a lot of wealth
over the last 50 years has been towards
the 1% of civilization and that's
because a lot of times they've invested
into the infrastructure that's made a
creativity and the mass of physiological
needs ubiquitous for us okay we'll give
them that it's true at the same time the
whole culture of 50 our fifth car fifth
Rolex etc is dying and Millennials and
Gen Z are catching on to the sniffing on
to it's super fast they know that
meaning purpose and fulfillment are the
top of self-actualization and so the
question becomes how do we make this
work for us all how do we build out the
the resource flows so that we can
empower more people at their creative
best with these technologies that are
coming out you're asking deep questions
that go I think a beyond even I
nice Oh some idea look we have idea
that's right here's why Yeah right the
truck drivers that are about to get laid
off
there's an argument in Silicon Valley
that we should do guaranteed minimum
income for people like that right just
give you a four thousand dollars a month
or whatever the check is and we're gonna
give them I don't think that's sellable
to America first of all I don't think
that's right because of what you just
said mission purpose that is a bad way
to treat human beings for a lot of
reasons
but my dad took me out took my family my
DNA strand out of poverty in one
generation Wow
he had a GI Bill he went to the army for
a couple of years and when he got out
they paid for his education and he got a
PhD was the first person in our family
to go to college and that got him to
Silicon Valley where I'm sitting with
you today right I've seen a school down
in Silicon Valley called Silicon Valley
42 that took a chef who did not have any
computer experience and today is running
a PR company two years later so I know
it's possible to take a truck driver and
retrain them to a computer science
that's for programming yeah with a free
school with no teachers Wow all right
now there is some infrastructure in the
school that it has a building and it has
computers so that he can he could go
someplace and work in a team and that
gives a lot more meaning and purpose and
actualization when they went in two
years now it are you willing to learn
something new if you're struggling to
feed your family and you're having to
drive uber to try to just put money on
that so hard so so happy
so I argue that instead of talking about
guaranteed minimum income we should be
talking about a new GI bill for
everybody to four years free ride but
you have to go to school you have to put
the glasses on you have to put the
glasses on yeah you have to put the
glasses on and be in it you ask
Worcester you know yeah soon they won't
be ugly and they won't and they'll be a
really high resolution and we can learn
together and you can be imprinted in
Pasadena where you live I can be here
and we can be doing all sorts of crazy
stuff location agnosticism working on
the same project learning the code yeah
correct
so yeah but it's just big and ugly and
it cost $3500 right yeah soon that won't
be a bat won't be I'm so yeah yeah and
then in the 2020s which is how we're
talking about this the crossover you
know like a proximity thing like
right next to each other so my idea so
my background is actually in economics
and finance and I worked on Wall Street
for eight years as an equity research
analyst I've seen how investors bankers
work I understand
how funds are raised and how companies
do their IPOs that's gotta change okay
there's no reason in the world why
regular everyday people shouldn't be
able to share in the wealth of new
company new companies that are being IP
owed especially because in many ways
they've helped create
III just customer of uber and Amazon etc
why not have a universal basic asset for
those that contributed to even a very
minor stake but still with the thousands
of rides that people have taken at the
company and thousands of items they have
purchased from the Amazon store why not
give them a minor stake in the ownership
it's an update maybe we should be paid
for our data and being able that that
yeah that's how we redistribute so I
think people would actually really up
for that and the whole privacy issue
would start to melt if we put a price we
are actually able to give people money
for it and those that want to to sell
their debt for their data will do it and
those that want to will not and that's
how it solves a lot of that issue
but I mean in terms of everyday people
being able to like have a lot of wealth
from IPOs that are happening here in San
Francisco and Silicon Valley I don't see
any reason why it wouldn't be able to be
the case except for the existing system
that's been like that for quite a while
that would make it extremely hard for
that to happen so I'm hopeful in the
future that it'll be a direct way that
people can actually contribute money and
get a lot back
you know instead of waiting until you
know they could buy stocks on the stock
market that's the rate you should be
able to get in when I brought a friend
of mine was on Sherrod up a little prop
jet playing a prop plane with Reed
Hoffman before Reed started LinkedIn and
he put something like a hundred grand in
because Reed said hey can you invest in
my new company one hundred thousand men
he pulled tens of millions out right but
only rich people who have a plane with
something like that have that kind of
access the access yeah and you have to
be an accredited investor I mean you
have to be somebody with millions of
dollars in assets that you can play with
I'm sure there would be millions of
people who would be willing to put in
ten dollars right to equal the amount
that's seated yeah it doesn't matter
where the money is coming from in terms
of the money yeah it matters to the
people where it's coming and we're
starting to see a blockchain of
approaches to real estate the Trust's
like this where you can invest 10 bucks
in us building yeah right and have some
payback for being them right you know
because most people can't afford a
million dollar apartment yeah or
certainly not a hundred million dollar
but what's happening with banks banks
are you know gonna be virtual most of
the banks screaming virtual banks you're
not gonna have
the existing banks of today probably I'd
say 40 years from now most of them will
be kind of changed maybe less yeah all
right I mean we had to go to a bank and
that was the first time walked into a
bank in a long time - over two hours
just oh here can you sign this form oh
we have another form for you to sign and
we need to look this up and it's just to
open a business you know checking
account yeah anyway and soon we're gonna
be able to do that in our glasses with a
remote banker who will scan the forms
and they'll appear in our area and we'll
sign with our finger or with our printer
with our eyes right our eyes are a
fingerprint and we'll talk to Siri and
say hey Siri will you approve that form
write something like that or Alexa or
Google assistant right hey Google lets
you know improve that farm and boom okay
the solutions are very complex but
updates in civilizational protocols and
codes in order to enable it are
extremely important and the solutions
that you laid out were we're good we
have a lot to put we have a lot of faith
in the young people and to do this yeah
hopefully from simultaneously a
grassroots level and uh and an industry
level and a governance level it can all
come together into into the good updates
that we need okay on the way I want to
mention we kind of touched on this a
little bit for those that are interested
I think it's important for you guys to
explain what unity and Unreal Engine are
which are the code and the design in
developing tools for arv are mixed
realities and how people can get
introduced to them and started with them
I mean in the eighties there was a
company that sprung out called
dobe that you know create it created a
tool called illustrator that let you
create graphics like this these graphics
are a little line right now vector
that's that's how it worked and then
another app called Photoshop came on
which was a grid of pixels like a camera
great at pixels and those two ideas were
how you created graphic design a piece
of paper or on a screen yeah yeah unity
and unreal are that for the 3d world
because we're moving from the world
that's like this to a world that's like
this three men noise wasn't fun so it's
moving to a 3d world so how do I make
you have a costume on your face that
would be done in unity or or unreal
matter depth-sensing to that then how no
I'm just talking about unity is a 3d yes
correct a game engine how do but then
the question is how do I build things
like you could do regular game community
but it's it's it's it's and we can move
the tree on the couch ten feet away 30
feet away 50 away and because we're in
3d dynamically adjust the code yes and
you can bring assets from other
companies and apps in from that more
from the ball because this is real
liquid job simulator a game that you
play in VR that was built in unity when
you pour the cup they have polygons
coming out and hitting the table yeah
right yeah and that's all code all done
in unity and the polygons that are
spraying out of the cup we're all
designed in unity right unity is like
Photoshop and illustrator together but
for the 3d world and actually unity and
unreal believe it or not
are not that hard to learn no you can
learn on YouTube that's another job that
people could do yeah you can learn on
YouTube you can go to YouTube teach me
how to use unity it's certainly easier
than most programming languages yeah I
mean I mean people are talking about you
know AI machine learning and tensorflow
and all of that that that's very thorny
tricks math that is really heavy-duty
unity and unreal I mean you know you
could go to school for like three months
and come out and ready to create a
project it's okay relatively I here if
you don't have any programming
understanding I mean you do need to
understand a little bit about computing
you know it helps to understand this
this this is all the creating vectors
and creating in the computer right yeah
yeah it's so if you if you came out of
space and landed here you have to do a
little more work but it's that's is if
we can find this now on on the internet
and in a couple months learn unity and
then there's their schools that'll teach
you how to be a programmer and pay for
you to land this school oh yeah and then
they'll take a percentage of the of the
salary afterwards yeah interesting yeah
yeah yeah we've been trying to get
someone from Liam to school we'll end up
doing that in a bit okay
all right and let's wrap on we talked a
lot on 5g we talked a lot on movies we
started touching a little bit on the
other industries here but you know we'll
have to do another round where we get
deeper retail correct yeah
yes yes logistics AG edge at the game
developer conference so this is sort of
how how new jobs are coming on right I'm
at the game developer conference at the
VR party and I made a guy who runs who's
building something for the supply chain
trucking and manufacturing and they just
turned on a their first cold storage
completely automated warehouse right
just this month turned on so think about
that all robots inside no they don't
move in salad
you know salad comes in on one truck
moves around it goes out the other side
he says that every palate has now a
sensor array they know how much jostling
each thing had and what temperature it
was whether it if they're shipping it
across the United States they know
exactly how the rate at which one of the
AC units on the truck is failing because
the temperature keeps going up right
[Applause]
that are applicable to the vertical yeah
yeah a medic a guy runs an oil refinery
in Canada it said you know it's funny
but the analysts who watch my industry
know that my factory is down before I do
and I go how did it how did they do that
well they put a CubeSat keeps that up in
space watches the temperature of my
factory yeah from space and reports to
the analyst that a that factory is cold
so it's offline and they know before he
gets a call from the shop farm and says
hey we just went off on
yeah all the way up to satellites and
how quickly you can get data from the
satellites as well spacial competing is
computing you can move you or a virtual
beam we haven't even started talking
about virtual beans that's a whole
nother show magical beings and people
moving through competing and it's reai
characters well yeah I did that's
virtual beings well no okay there's a
difference all right tell me what
virtual beans could be a duplicate of
you okay AI character is a fictional
character that is developed that uses
natural language processing and machine
learning to be able to talk to you as if
they're a real person yeah so they could
be quite different I've put that all in
but oh yeah it's all in virtual B
there's a virtual influencer in China
that had 40,000 people watch a concert
she's not real she's up on a screen and
40,000 people went to watch a concert of
her think about that one so virtual
influencers are now at it was actually
filmed pretty well too yeah yeah yeah oh
wow yeah we talk about cultural shifts
this stuff is going to deeply change our
culture we're gonna in the next decade
we're gonna go through something like we
went to in the 60s where culture is just
crazy changed cars we we don't yet have
movies that have self-driving cars in
them right and movies are our culture
the sci-fi some sci-fi hell yeah in the
dark yeah not in the not in there real
movies where kids go to a shopping mall
yeah you know kind of move huh I'm
excited for round three a shopping mall
it's a place you gotta play VR at
actually cuz they're gonna rip down the
inside of a mall and you're gonna go
with your goggles and go play somebody
are we your friends right the amount of
Industry applications are endless and
I'm looking forward when we sit down
again we can dive in to a lot of these
AI agents and we can talk about more of
the industry applications in the in the
nuance and the big scale the satellite
view scale on on earth and the way that
it's going to impact our children that
are growing up so yeah let's um let's do
it let's do this again with a round
three and let's see if with this all
this 2020s knowledge that you've been
just soaking up like a sponge about the
profound shift does it feel like we're
in a simulation anymore than it did a
year ago
oh why would it make a difference if you
believe here in a simulation it always
kind of made you know I go in and out of
that actually there are there are days
where I do feel like I'm in a simulation
on Saturday night I was holding a rock
in my hand that was six billion years
old and supposedly is how life formed on
earth
I don't know the simulation question is
one of those questions that billionaires
ask each other over dinner it's sort of
like a funny thing like what can we put
in to the press and into social media
that's not provable either way it has
real consequences either way like if you
believe in simulation and I don't
believe in some legend
it's an interesting dinner conversation
it is really relevant to the idea of a
created environment we're talking about
that's right so if we are the puppeteers
of this new creative environment that's
three dimensional and looks completely
real why can't there be something that's
doing that with us that's right so I
don't know maybe some days yes some days
I'm like no so it depends agree I don't
think there's a guy playing with this
thing no no I thing called analog to us
right
analog and I like the wave of photons to
hitting that plant is a lot oh this is a
lot of law you can go on for years
Neil Young Muller taught me the
difference between digital and our Neil
Young the rock singer he took me into
studio and let me listen to harvest moon
on his two-inch analog tape deck in the
studio where he coordinates oh it's
pretty bad outside
do you often
and then we listen to it on digital when
he could when his audio engineer cut it
from analog to digital digital as
numbers right so music on our phone is
numbered France there's numbers in here
that smooth this can be devised a number
number wise but you're perceiving it in
an analog so that's our sensory system
which is made but out of math and
physics level yes right good yeah
there was a gap yeah between the digital
music and the analog yeah yeah even at
high resolution you know 600 kilohertz
per second it's 10 times more than a CD
CD is 40 for 12 times more right CD is
44 point 1 kilohertz 44,000 slices of
numbers per second right that's music on
Spotify right and so even if you ant
that up to really a lot more slices
still again and that's why people are
like oh when we get black air on our
pace right and when we get the perfect
optic is 32 K or 84k or whatever is
gonna be in the future or jacked right
into our optic nerve people are get
still seek out
because there still will be a difference
there there it might get interesting I
think you may be the first one that's
said that no matter how good the
technology gets that there will still be
a difference there will be a difference
and you'll seek it out here and there I
mean we already are a friend of mine yet
just two days ago picked me up and his
older BMW and said let's talk about the
difference between your Tesla and my
analog old crappy car which has some
attributes to it it is a very analog
machine it has analog it has a different
feel to it a different experience to it
a different noise to it right and humans
will seek that out on a racetrack right
you will pay a lot of money to drive
that car in the future on a racetrack
where you can get that engine going
I have a theory that view it right yes
in analog yeah because she's gonna say
we're gonna wear the glasses that drive
that car and I'm saying that at some
point you won't be able to tell the
difference using your sensory perception
I say that's wrong okay privileged thing
to experience I'm saying it this way man
we're gonna come out in a different way
way toward the slums and in
many billions of people around the world
and you don't even have to go to slum go
to Shenzhen where I got a tour in China
and I met a college professor so a
fairly high person in society and he
lives in a 600 square foot box with
three people in that box it's not like
this it's America still even though our
our housing value is getting so
expensive that people are starting share
more and more space it's far worse for
most people around the world and they
don't have the money to travel 20% of
Americans have a passport
80% don't so I've experienced the Taj
Mahal in its analog glory and it is
glorious to put your hand on that thing
and see the dual work and that work on
that stone but she's right
most people will never experience the
analog and the digital beep but I'm just
saying it's something I'll catch up
no I there will always be a difference
if you go to the analog thing there Neil
Young proved it to me even at a high
resolution
now digital is still not the smooth way
it's not it's just as digital plus this
is still transistors which are light
switches that go on and off they're
still you can put billions and trillions
of them on this thing the gap will be so
small that it'll be hard to tell but
there still will be a gap more by the
way by the way here's another way to
look at it right now there's gamma rays
going through you that you can't feel
you can't but if I had a sensor I could
shown to you well there's so are the
realities that were hardly sensing
something in the ally world that even
when you even when you get the trillions
of semiconductors on your glasses even
when you get jacked into the optic nerve
that I can you tell the difference the
other problem is school my kids by the
time they're 40 they're gonna get jacked
into their optic nerve yeah and they
might choose never to experience them
that's another philosophical question
the brain in the bat they might this is
over
yeah come back on they might yeah yeah
and that'll be like which pill is that I
forget well I want digital like beamed
into my mind yeah cuz that'll be
something totally totally beamed in my
mind that movie just comes into my mind
but that taking that surgery or putting
that into my optic nerve means I'll
never acceptable you're already in that
you're in that world already the old rod
says the only thing that we're gonna
learn when we get closer to the real
into single virtual reality is that this
already is virtual reality
so I want to meet the programmer yeah we
will will be the programmers and meeting
the programmers all at the same time
hell yeah I will this is a simulation
it's a badass for a great I am very
deeply grateful that we were able to
have this round two
it was very profoundly enlightening and
we're looking forward to infinite retina
and all the work that you guys will be
doing here yes major cheers to you guys
yes great job putting this together yeah
it's exciting and the team's very
powerful and your knowledge base about
what's happening is very powerful in
you're already doing really good
interviews as well if you guys find
infinite retinas YouTube channel they're
already doing powerful interviews with
thought leaders in the space
there's the 360 camera that we're using
this because it's a new tool for
storytelling that yes radically gonna
change media yes yes yes soon we'll have
360 camera on simulation you'll be able
to look at all of our different faces
all swiping through as you please
joining us right here in the center of
the table thank you again for coming on
thank you thank you so much Robert thank
you so much really appreciate you both
tremendously thank you everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it we
would love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on today's episode go and
share more conversations about what all
this technology is going to enable go
and share with your friends your family
online at your workplaces everywhere you
go go and start talking about it more
sharing it around if you shout out to
Ron Vargas our producer and director
thank you very much for the show and
support the artisan entrepreneurs that
you believe in support the organizations
around the world
that are making tremendous impact goal
and support simulation our links are
below as well and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world thank you so much for tuning in
and we will see you soon
[Music]
[Music]